what is a behavior report there are
several types of behavior reports they
show the performance of our content and
the action visitors took it visualized
the past users travel from one page to
another or from one event to the next in
apps it will be from screen to screen
these reports can help you discover what
potential content keeps user engage it
also can help you undefiled issues okay
let's see how to use it here we'll just
click in the behavioral pain on overview
and we'll get the first report the
overview give you a high level summary
of what users interact with your site or
app for instance here you can see the
page views the unique time on page
bounce rate and many more if you want to
see the full report just go to the
bottom and click and you'll get all the
detailed scenarios and data of what
happened with your site another very
useful report is the behavioral flow if
you clicked on it you'll see what are
the paths that users took when they
travel to your site this report could
help you and let the five potential
problems or where are the pages that the
users are most engaged with